shots being fired in western Ukraine on
the border with the EU in July the town
of McCarver was the site of a fierce gun
battle involving ultra-nationalists
right sector gunmen and private security
guards of pro-russian members of
parliament there were numerous
casualties the Nationalists fled into
the mountains with the security forces
in pursuit suddenly checkpoints have
sprung up in western Ukraine previously
they were limited to the east a second
front in the Ukraine conflict Kennedy
Moscow the new regional governor is the
man who should know more scholars Kiev's
best known crisis manager and was sent
here personally by President Petro
poroshenko after the shootings obispo
Rodman the perpetrators saw the weakness
of the police here in the Carpathian
region for six months perpetrators have
terrorized the area around mocha Java
and the border town of Garad list
suddenly the phone rings the new
governor has only been in office for a
few days many officials of the regional
administration were fired by President
poroshenko after the shooting an
informant is on the phone Georgia 323
stage play beautifully yeah only they're
making free goods I know that the
smugglers will be able to use that
smuggling and corruption takes center
stage here in the capacitance gone
through Bundy gangs have completely
corrupted the regional administration
the fighting with the right sector group
was apparently over the illegal
cigarette and drug trade on the border
with the EU the fighters were reportedly
receiving twenty five percent of the
profits that was clearly not enough now
the gang warfare in the Carpathian
region has left the extreme nationalists
and their leader Dmytro yarosh with a
lot of explaining to do we don't take
part in the fights between gangs of
smugglers here in the West such a battle
may exist but i'm not sure between who
it's been an embarrassment for the
right-wing group to admit that there are
corrupt members in their kapadia and
stronghold it's a beautiful region but
with massive economic problems it's
exactly here in the Carpathian Mountains
were Ukraine's president poroshenko
might have to prove whether he takes his
fight series against the endemic
corruption in Ukraine the borders with
Hungary and Slovakia are notorious for
corruption among customs officials and
police officers in cities like Oscar
rude expensive villas have sprung up in
the otherwise impoverished area
Kevin user eighty percent of the
district of Chevy Nature has been built
up with money from my vodka yes my vodka
I'd sell the bottle for sixty cents and
they sold it on in the West for three
times that now others have taken over
the trade here after the Maidan protests
pro-russian politicians let the right
sector nationalists in on their business
but the recent incidents indicate that
there's been some falling out between
them now Kiev really has another front
line to fight at in the war against
corruption in western Ukraine